the biggest boss move that you can make
in the marketplace is look what everyone
else is charging for and then create a
product or service that's better than
the thing they charge for and give it
away for free it is one of the fastest
way to rise and build brand in a
Marketplace and add Goodwill the way
that you know when to sell stuff is that
you keep giving and you keep giving
until they ask so look at our product or
service that doesn't cost a lot of money
or is free to replicate so think
software think media think low touch
services and do that for people for free
I'll say it again do it for free and
make it better than what other people
are charging for when you do that you
will have viral Word of Mouth that
starts expanding and your brand will
build and the moment you do want to
charge for something you will have a
line of people out your door waiting to
hand you money